absolutely
[Music]
I would have led well a few months ago
the Rugby World was shocked with the
ejection of one of the great English
rugby clubs in London Irish to me that
might just look like another club gone
but the reality of that is that so many
players and staff have an incredibly
tough transition to do so for this
episode I've got a guest who loved the
club more than anyone I know he is a
very passionate London Irish man he's
also reached the Pinnacle of the game
representing the wallabies and on top of
all the footy stuff he is just an
all-round Champion lad it is the great
Oliver Hoskins welcome mate thanks
brother good to be here mate thanks for
coming on obviously super gutting to see
what's what's happened over there not
just for London ice really but for the
other two clubs as well hard times for a
lot of players but I thought it'd be
awesome to get you on and get a little
bit of insight into what it's been like
as a player going through all of this
yeah man it's been a it's been a wild
month or so
um a lot of chaos a lot of instability
um yeah it feels like I'm almost like
mourning a loss of a relationship in a
way like it's been Irish like you were
there on my foot when I first rocked out
we both rocked up at the same sort of
time and the transition we had from
playing in the champ and going to bloody
Rotherham to playing in the Champions
Cup this year and doing really well uh
to then everything just go and tits up
very quickly
um it's yeah I feel like I'm lost I'm
more than a loss of a of a relationship
almost because I was very emotionally
attached to the club and not just me
there's like I think the reality was
like 140 odd people involved in the club
being like a player's staff Academy
Foundation members all this sort of
stuff and everyone was just made
redundant the other week and we're just
like
wow I guess you gotta scramble and try
to find a new job which isn't the best
when 50 players suddenly flood the
market at the worst possible time once
everyone's got their squad sorted for
next year so it's been a
it's been a pretty shitty couple of
weeks not gonna lie but we've um we
Soldier on on to the next one yeah and
you mentioned how many players 50
players and that's on top of already
another two clubs that have gone under
as well so I read the other day that
there's 119 players looking for
contracts at the moment so it's
obviously a really flattered Market
incredibly stressful for any player
who's you know all they've got is rugby
that's been their job for their whole
whole life and now all of a sudden it's
being taken away from them scrambling
for anything yeah it's it's wild like
the rep the spring into my agent went
just before when we had inklings this
was going on we'll like kind of trying
to figure stuff out in case the worst
case scenario and good thing good thing
we got onto it early but like he was
telling me he had a bunch of boys at
wasps and Worcester
um and it was like the reality of it is
I had to have conversations with
probably 60 70 of them being like
there's not going to be a job for you
and the majority of those boys still
aren't playing again unless they want to
go and play for peanuts in the champ or
whatever but the reality of it if you're
like a
if you're a 28 to 30 early 30s outside
back or Center or whatever
but the demand for that it just isn't
unless you're a world-class one if
you're just like in and out of the squad
uh play a few Prem games here kind of
Off the Bench a few times like the the
chances of you getting a job when you've
got all these International guys
suddenly flooding the market like
it's not it's just it's so low so the
reality is though most of the boys are
just
done now just for Stuff completely out
of their control
um when they had security of like I had
two years left of my deal that Irish
made I mean the wife are like trying to
set stuff up and in London and you have
this Financial Security and she just
started a new job and all this sort of
stuff and other boys are in the exact
same position and staff members it's
just like rug pulled and all of a sudden
you're like oh damn I haven't I didn't
get paid last month I'm not getting paid
this month if I do get a deal
they start in July so I'm not gonna get
paid to the end of July and you just
join like in London you know Orlando
rent's not exactly the cheapest cheapest
thing going around so yeah it's been
squeaky bum time I'm not gonna lie for
for everybody
so how's that worked you haven't been
paid for the last two months is that
from when you found out that the club
was gone or was that before that and
you're the rest of your two-year
contract is just done now nothing yeah
the rest the rest of the two years is
dust because the club went into
Administration essentially so they made
us all redundant and because the club
went into Administration they obviously
don't have the money to pay boys out
their contracts or any of that sort of
stuff
um so we got
last month we got 50 of our wages in a
like that was like a deal that our old
owner did to try and extend the deadline
for them to get this this other deal
over the line
um and then so obviously then this month
nothing and then boys who have managed
to secure a deal won't get paid again
until end of July so it'll be pretty
much pretty much two in a bit months
um going with nothing and then one month
and like half pay
um so yeah and like a lot of boys you
know how rugby is the majority of you
have you have the operation on a guy's
own in real earning good money and it
will be sweet and have savings put away
and then there's like a lot of a lot of
I don't think fans and stuff understand
the reality of pro 40 is like the
majority of boys who are in squads who
are Squad players who are in and out of
teams are like maybe seven a little bit
but a lot of them are living paycheck to
paycheck sort of thing and then this
comes around when you're in London and
you've got a family and guys have kids
and [__] and it's like bang sorry here's
half your wages and then nothing and
it's just so it's brutal man it's brutal
right that is so tough and have you
heard from any of the players like what
what's the majority of these guys doing
who haven't picked up again okay yeah
we've still got like all our WhatsApp
groups going and stuff um and it's it's
weird like on our blood and Irish group
there's just been boys posting stuff
about transitioning out of rugby work
experience opportunities it's just like
and all these boys obviously like four
weeks ago they were had deal sign and
they're like I'm playing for the Irish
the next couple of years and stuff and
then all of a sudden a few of the boys
I'm speaking to have gone and done work
experience in like in London in the city
and stuff
um other guys are
still trying to find a job some guys are
trying to hold out and you know wait for
an injury during the World Cup or
something and hopefully get a gig that
way
um but yeah it's just it's so much
instability
um and as you know like the financial
stress of it all is like I feel for so
many boys that are like oh I'm lucky I'm
lucky in the fact that I've been at
Irish for a while
and I like I play international so like
I've got a bit of money put away but
like London eats away at that pretty
quick but there's a there's a lot of
boys especially with us who just
wouldn't have more than a month's bills
in the bank and then now they're just
like have to take what I can get or try
figure something out I feel for them
it's it it's brutal especially the staff
like you know there's the staff members
are like the guys who are in the media
team or doing ticketing and all that
sort of stuff they're they're even in
worse position than us like
and I know there's there's people worse
off in the world and like I don't want
to sit here and act like it's a big sob
story but the reality of it is is that
like guys are pretty a lot of boys would
be up [__] creek right now and coming
off the back of probably the best season
for London Irish and a long long time
too did you did you pick it did you know
this was in the pipeline or how'd you
find out about it
um I mean there was like I know Mick our
old owner he came out pretty early in
this season being like I want to sell
the club which I thought was just like
uh you know owners want to sell the club
those kind of thing they're not just
gonna
I just turn it to dust
um but yeah that was kind of earlier on
in the year and I know that some boys
when they were renegotiating like mid
like in their normal sort of time frame
like say a season there's contracts
going from like July to July over here
and usually if you're negotiating for
the next next season you kind of start
chatting around November Chris around
Christmas time sort of and then you get
a deals done early in the in the year I
know some boys will like asking heaps of
questions then about
um like this long-term stability of the
club and I was like a bit shocked when I
heard that as well of course with sweet
Mick just wants to sell it we'll be fine
um yeah and then and then we got like
inklings of this American people buying
the club and everyone's like okay sweet
he's got a deal we're just sorting out
the logistics of it
um and then we didn't really like know
anything was properly up until there was
probably like a month before
we really we like got our pay got
delayed there was like this random
article that came out in the in the
papers over here saying that like Irish
players may not get paid this month and
I was actually away from we had a week
off and I was like away with a wife and
children and stuff and I woke up at like
7am my dad had sent me this article
being like oh were you getting paid and
I was like so confused and actually like
I feel bad now I kind of like Snapped at
my dad being like Dad I'm on holiday
stop sending me this fake news like
pissed off made no he's no I look like a
real dick
um but yeah that um that was like the
first sort of inkling and then Irish
came out and said no this is Mrs
bollocks and they paid us and everything
was sweet and then the month after that
we usually get paid like the night
before the last day of the month and it
was a Thursday and we came into training
on the Friday and no one had been no one
had been paid and everyone was like oh
it's a bit weird well what's going on
and then we kind of just like went
through the day and then before we went
out for our um our field session in the
afternoon our like CEO
boss information meeting was like oh you
know went for money from the US sorry
guys pay is going to be delayed and then
just like we had a little chat about it
and then just like cracked on with the
day and everyone was like what the hell
and then we had like a team meeting and
I remember the coaches like put on this
like it's like I think they knew it was
coming they kind of put on this straight
after that meeting we had this like team
like quiz thing to try and up the mood
and like to get some laughs and then we
like went out and trained and it was
just it was so weird
sorry mate you're not getting your wages
today but go out and I do do a couple of
Live scrums And then just so I go we'll
give you a quiz yeah we gave you a quiz
and a few live scrums let's go it was
just yeah it was such a weird vibe and
then um and then we were like leading
into our last game of the year
and we hadn't been paid like the whole
week going into that last game
um and then the day before we were like
advised to hand in these like contract
breach notes and all this sort of stuff
and then I think that kind of prompted
them to our current owner to like
to actually pay us
um and then we got then we got paid the
day before the game and everything went
went on and we got told that this deal
is going to get done the next month and
everything's sweet
um but yeah it didn't uh that didn't
eventuate unfortunately so we got we got
one last pay to finish off the season
then we went to offseason like normal we
had our exit meetings everything we'd
planned for the next preseason all that
sort of stuff and then obviously just
like as this we're all meant to be on
our off-season break and it was just
like every other day having meetings
about
Club Going Under And when you find your
agent every day it was just like the
least relaxing break of all time right I
bet yeah
so how did they break the news to you
eventually
um were you like the I feel like in a
way uh the the our owners stopped like
giving us pretty much any any info after
a while because every time he'd give us
info we'd have like a players meeting
and then it would be in the media like
15 minutes later some boys obviously
telling their agents their agents like
Bank getting on the getting on the phone
to I don't know who
um so Mick stop like stop giving us any
info after a while
um because I don't think they wanted
stuff to get leaked and obviously it was
making Irish look bad and making these
us people look bad and all that sort of
stuff so we literally like before until
the actual deadline
like until five minutes before none of
us have like heard anything and we just
had like a sort of whole staff players
everyone jumped on a zoom and um even
then like our CEO who was kind of like
he's a he's an employee as well so I
felt a bit bad because he was just kind
of like the shooting the messenger every
time he'd come up and speak in front of
us boys were just like grilling him this
poor boy he'd stand up and just be like
I don't have any news I just like I'm
just relaying what I getting told by
people and but and he was obviously the
face of it and boy he was just getting
grilled by everybody a bit so he hopped
on this zoom and he was like no I think
we're we're still all there's still hope
like we're still good and literally I
was looking at my watch and like the
deadline was at like 8pm and it was like
7 59 it's like no we're good we're gonna
do this and then we're on the zoom and
one of the one of our coaches put in
there like well what do you have to say
about this statement that just got
released and he like sat there and was
like
oh [__] like and then he just sat and
read this entire statement which at
about that point I was just like lost my
head and like put it on mute because I
couldn't listen to it because it was
like I was just like oh wow I've just
lost my job and like I just like turned
the camera off put it on mute was like
crying and stuff because obviously I've
just I'm so I loved playing for this
club so much and it was like reading out
a statement saying how we all just got
suspended and it was just like so
overwhelming like the players chat was
popping off as the as the zoom was on
everyone was just like oh it's just a uh
looking back on it I'm sure I'll look
back on in a couple months and it'll be
comical like the way it all went down
because it was just honestly was like a
soap opera like you couldn't write a
script whereas we just got promised
thousands of times sorry got promised
thousands of times that [__] was getting
done and it just like never did so it
was just so it was I'm sure in a couple
of months he'll look back and be like I
can't believe that happened but at the
moment it's still so so fresh it was so
weird man oh mate you might have to make
the money back by doing it uh we TV
Netflix you could you could make a
doctor
about it it's like yeah it's it was just
um I don't know it was just a debacle
mode the whole whole thing it's like I'm
not I'm not
anyone it's not I don't know if anyone
specifically is to blame or whatever
just I just think we were all always
under the illusion that thing was going
to get done
and even to like even literally with a
minute left everyone was like yeah this
is getting done with sweet and then it
was just side bang so like even though
I'd prepped for I was in the process of
like prepping for if the worst case
scenario I don't think I ever fully
believed that it was um it was gonna
come
um and then when it did it was just like
the realization hit you like a ton of
bricks and you're just like I don't
really know what to do right now it was
just like such an emotional couple of
days honestly like
I think you people who know me like I'm
quite a I wear my heart my sleeve I'm
very like an emotional bloke I don't
mind having a crying stuff and I was
like I just like just got off that zoom
and I'll just sitting in my room my wife
is at work so I was actually like in my
bed by myself just like sobbing and my
dog ran upstairs and was like look at me
and stuff and I was like get my dog a
cuddle and I was like oh God this is
just this is just wild
all right so then what's your next steps
from there you get told the news
um yeah you're in your big crime with
the dog licking yes
how do you get back what's what's the
next step God uh yeah I've I told I had
a Five Guys I need some dopamine I was
like I deserve a deserve a burger right
now so I'm just like well I've got back
from work and we both were just like
kind of debriefing and obviously like
it's just it's just as stressful for
your families like I felt like
I feel like I had no control in this
scenario whereas like I can at least
still kind of work with my agent and
figure out what I'm doing next if I can
get a job whereas like my wife is just
just has to sit there and be like well I
guess she has literally zero control of
what goes on so like it's so stressful
for her and we're both just like
trying to figure out and process what
happened
and then like yeah we just had a had a
weird night and then next day I started
straight away onto the on the phone to
the agent and trying to get stuff sorted
out and it just so but as you know
everyone just floods a market at the
same time so it's yeah imagine part of
the clubs are like let's go I can get I
can get good players on a big old
discount here absolute bargain hunting
they're going around the marketplace
it's been like auctioning us off I
imagine um but but even then because
other clubs you know the salary cap at
the Prem is going went down for this
next year to like compensate for covert
so clubs have even less money to spend
um and then most of them obviously got
their squads filled up so
boys that want to stay around in the
Prem like they're only realistic sort of
thing is if clubs have injury
dispensations so I think I think the way
it works is if if someone has a
long-term injury you can like use
whatever money they make and you sign
someone else in the same position sort
of thing
um outside of the cap I think that's how
it works something to do with that so
like boys who who are getting deals of
got deals are mainly due to other clubs
having long-term injuries and if they
don't have if clubs don't have injuries
in your position it's kind of like
you're forced to either move overseas or
you're up [__] creek sort of thing so
what were your options obviously like
you say negotiation power is pretty low
yeah
um what were your options was it ever
thought of you returning back to Aussie
or Amazon UK I had um I had some chat or
not me directly but my agents had chats
with with a few Aussie teams and that
was definitely a an option but as you
know like the super or the Australian
contractor from like December or
November and I was kind of here in June
um needing in employment if I was going
to go back to Oz I needed to find
something to cover me for this next six
months before I go back and then it was
just all this logistical logistical
stuff of within a couple of literally
within a couple of days gone from
thinking I'm in London for the next two
years to if I move back to I was having
to tell my wife moving on the other side
of the world and or when I was chucking
my dog on a plane and all this sort of
like all this stuff like during this
process it was funny like you speak to
speak to so many people and they were
just like oh that's horrible but just go
to Japan or just go to France or you
know just just go go home and I was like
yeah it's a little bit like there's a
little bit more to it like I know we're
footy players but like we actually do
have a life outside of rugby and just
like moving over the other side of the
world isn't just like as simple as if I
was like a single bloke as I was when I
moved over here
did have any dependence or whatever just
oh yeah this is this is whatever I'll
just go chase the dollar
um yeah but it's like you have to think
about stuff in a bit more of a holistic
sort of way so yeah I had um I chose to
a few teams back home we looked in
France
um a few teams in in the UK and stuff
but yeah that's what I'm sort of now so
I signed with saris Simon saracens which
is which is uh which is a good thing for
for us me and my wife and stuff like
allows us to stay in London they're
obviously an awesome club like they put
put you in positions like they've got a
track record of um of developing players
into world-class players
um give put you in a good position to
win some of the biggest trophies in the
world obviously so
like you know like apart from this year
with with Irish you haven't been
incredibly unfairly successful apart
from that those massive Champions we've
won the Championships me and you mate
you know playing bloody Yorkshire
Carnegie at the madstad one of the great
days
so yeah that was a I don't know just
weighing up stuff holistically like me
and my wife have such an awesome life
outside of rugby in London we got like a
awesome friendship group that have
nothing to do with footy so I can like
really disconnect from rugby like it's a
big thing for me as as I've got older
having that sort of sort of well-rounded
self-identity and being like I'm a rugby
player which is a portion of who I am as
a bloke and then also having all these
other aspects of my life that are really
important to me off the field have
helped me deal with what's going on
right now I feel like if this has
happened when I was like 25 24 25 I
would have been like broken because I
just
I was just olly Hoskins rugby player I
didn't have much else to mow it's my
identity everything I did was just 40 40
footy footy whereas now I've got like
great mates outside of rugby I've got
things that bring me joy outside with my
with my marriage and my dog and all this
sort of stuff whereas like everything
obviously professionally rugby was just
crumbling around me but I had all these
other pillars that were still sweet so I
had to kind of prioritize that in my
decision making here whereas I could
have tried and you know make up
Financial losses by chasing the
short-term dollar like there was an
option for me to go to
frauds on like a World Cup Joker sort of
thing while they and that would have
been that would have been awesome cash
but then I'd be in the same position in
December and probably forced to move
back to Australia or just be unemployed
and wait for another gig and then be in
the same sort of instability so having
that sort of uh stability outside of
footy was really big for me so we could
stay where we're living and I'll just
commute up to North London to get to
sarri's and allows my my wife who
literally just started a dream job
probably two weeks ago she she was
working in the corporate London grind
for a couple of years and she quit that
and spent the last year training to be a
yoga instructor and she just got she
just passed and just got a gig at a yoga
studio and building up clients and stuff
and then I was like sorry I love them I
have to ship you off somewhere so this
is all those things you have to think
about so yeah
um because you you know obviously you
know Kendo he's he's now at sarri's so
yeah chatting to him I know a few people
there they're like great great people I
went up and did a medical the other week
and all the stuff and they're awesome
and I know a few boys who play there
um and yeah it's just like for me I
think these next two years are really
about like developing as a player and
enjoying a new environment and
having some the stability off the field
helps me go there and just like rip in
and try and you know add to the group
and become as good a player as I can and
then I'll be off contract when I'm 32
and then I can focus on
potentially trying to make up some of
the lost the lost money that we've that
I've had to to cop now but there's just
so many other things that I had to think
about
um and Sarah's ticked like every single
box in in that in that sort of agenda so
I'm really happy man I'm excited I'm
excited mate series
is worse clubs in the world than uh
playing for series like exactly one of
the most successful clubs really in the
game to be fair so it's going to be
awesome for you to experience it how far
is that commute for you
probably on a good day if I leave early
enough we'll be just over an hour if I
get caught on traffic on the M25 it
could be a little bit longer so we um
well it's going to be an adjustment
because obviously I live in Richmond now
to get into sunbury's 15 15 minutes 20
minutes max so yeah that's right I'm
already up with the dog early so I'll
just walk in and then get in hop in the
carb just before seven o'clock and
hopefully get there just after eight and
then
it'll be it's going to be a change in
lifestyle it's just like one of those
things but it's a it's the most sort of
stable option when it comes to off-field
stuff and then also probably the best
place for me to progress as a player and
be in such an awesome environment
um it was kind of once once they sort of
came to the table it was like it was
pretty much a no-brainer for me it's I
was all science sort of sort of LED
there and yeah I'm a side of mate you
know like when you're in an environment
for so long I've been at Irish for
Seven Seasons now
um and I came there super young and I
came there like 20 just just turned 23
and now I'm 30 in a bit and developed a
lot as a as a player and also a bloke
off off the field like you can kind of
go into weeks or Seasons knowing exactly
what's happening you know I've been
there for so long I know exactly what I
what I before they even sent out the
schedule I know exactly what we're doing
on a seven day turnaround exactly what
we're doing on a six day turnaround I
know exactly the content of the sessions
so like you can almost get through a
week without really having to mentally
engage yourself at 100 almost ever and
then you just lock in for game day and
go whereas like being this new
environment with new coaches and New
Perspectives and new players and all
that sort of stuff I feel like it's
going to really like stimulate meant
mentally and probably and definitely
going to make me a better player because
I'm going to view the game from a
different perspective stuff that I had
never really had because I've been with
the same coaches for so long
um and I loved my time at Irish and I
was signed up for two more years I
wanted to I wanted to stay there but
this is going to definitely stimulate me
and and drive me to become a better
player just by thinking of the game and
viewing the game from different
perspectives and stuff and playing with
different people so yeah it's good it's
going to be an awesome move man I'm
really I'm really excited it's kind of
kind of made I'm one of the lucky ones
who's got a gig and this is like the
best the best outcome it could have been
for me in all last year awesome where
did the wallabies fit in it with all of
this like obviously you've played for
the wallabies Now where's the
conversations there
I I spoke to two super teams in in Oz
and they were both pretty Keen to have
me on board but I never had any sort of
communication with aru or
or Eddie Jones or anyone
um so like if I was gonna go back home
that probably would have been like a big
big thing for me I'd only sort of
make that massive sort of transition
because like even though I'm I'm
Australian like but I've got my most of
my adult life independent adult life has
been in the UK so I very much view
London is home now like I've I came here
as I was 22 but I was still a kid like I
was living at home in Perth when I moved
over the site so I've literally done all
my sort of maturing outside of rugby and
building relationships and friendships
and all that sort of stuff in the UK so
I very much view this as home so I've
viewed like a move back to Oz as
more of a massive transition than most
people would think going like oh go back
home to Oz but it's like I haven't
really I haven't been there for all my
adult life it doesn't really feel like
it is home but it's not really where
I've got my roots down like my plan is
to be in the UK after rugby I'm going to
stay around stay up here and stuff so
unless there was that sort of community
communication obviously not going to get
a complete guarantee that you come back
you're playing for the wallabies but
like
unless there was that sort of
communication or maybe something from
their end
going back there on a whim and uprooted
my entire life on a whim that I might
play for the wallabies a couple more
times is like it was it was something I
weighed up but it was just such a
massive transition for me and the family
and stuff that I don't know I just felt
like this was the best move for us
especially they're not grueling out in
the future maybe after this two years
maybe after six years I play well for
series and I've got communication with
wallabies and all that sort of stuff and
maybe that's that's an option but for
right now I just felt like there was
just so much
chaos going on in our lives that I was
like I needed to just lock down some
something that I can control as like
local geographical stability for the
wife and stuff and for me it just kind
of that that's what really drove this
decision that like I consider going back
but without like a firm conversation
with Eddie or anyone in the IU I was a
bit less like it's just too much too
much instability to go back on a whim
yeah makes total sense although it would
be good to see back in that front row
with your good mate Dave pareki and that
oh um
as soon as this happened of course he
texted me being like Oh yeah I think the
tiles need to tight headlight let's let
me get on to my boy I was like thanks
David looking after me that man is
unbelievable right but I am Keen to hear
obviously you said that you got to
London Irish 22. M Keen to hear a little
bit about that Journey before you got
over there growing up in Perth what was
that like for you it's a good place to
grow up as a kid I mean so I'm youngest
of three boys
um and my parents are both born in the
UK and they moved over when they were
very young I think my dad would have
been 20 a mum 21 and they moved over to
Perth so they moved to Brisbane
initially and then moved over to Perth
and had me and my brothers
um and Perth is not a rugby City at all
so it was kind of like my dad was rugby
nuts so he just like forced it down I
forced it down our throats but like for
me I I won't I when I was around my
brothers played and I was always kind of
grew up one of those kids grew up on the
sideline of a Rugby field when I was
younger
um and and yeah it's just uh it was good
it's a great place to grow up mate I
don't know if you've ever been to Perth
but it's very much just like a quiet
nice family sort of environment great
beaches that sort of thing
um and yeah so I was just played played
footy there and got into the the Western
force was like my my life back in the
day the funny thing is like when I can't
remember the the year it might have been
two thousand
2003 or someone 2004 that the force came
in to Super Rugby I can't remember the
exact time but like my my mum and my
brother like organized when there was
like a bid between wa and Melbourne to
get the team my mum and brother
organized this like enormous supporters
rally and got like 25 000 people to
subiaco oval at the time to make this
giant human sign saying like Super Rugby
for Perth
um and like it got like massive news
headlines everywhere
um and that like apparently was actually
quite a big thing to get the team over
there so like my family was like massive
Western four super fans back in the day
I remember like now it's kind of it's
kind of cringe but I had like all the
guys jerseys up in my room and stuff and
then I was like in the academy and ended
up playing with a bunch of them and I'd
like took him down
I can't be playing with like pet cow and
I've got his like signed jersey up in my
room and stuff so that was so I um I was
like a super fan I go to every game and
I was like loved it yeah and then to go
through the academy and actually and
play for them was just like
I've made it in life and I thought like
I thought I was just gonna be on this
like linear trajectory of of rugby
around like Perth Perth Club rugby and
school rugby obviously isn't at the
highest level so I was just like
the big guy sort of big fish in a very
small pond and I was just like
smooth sound was always the best player
on every single every single team I went
on like every time I went on the pitch I
was one of the best players and then I
got to
Super Rugby and I played
um played pretty I think I debuted when
I was like 20 as a tight end and I was
like oh mate I'm flying this is just
going to be this linear trajectory I'm
played when I was 20 I'll be starting
for the force next year I'll play 100
wallabies cabs I'm gonna be played for
the force forever be the best player in
the world and then like and then I like
hit super and like I played I played
number eight most of my teenage years
and then I like moved to Thailand quite
late and I went to and I could get away
with being a [__] Scrambler Joe in like
Perth Club 40 or like some sort of even
when I played Aussie 20s and that sort
of stuff like I was average Scrolls but
it just never was a priority for me like
I just like as long as I've played well
around the park and was carrying and
having fun and then I was like I'm the
best player ever and I got to Super
Rugby and I was just like oh I'm
actually pretty [__] and it was just
like a massive massive reality check for
me
um and it humbled me quite a lot and
then the coach at the time was still
picking me like I think I played 26
super games and every single one of them
was off the bench I didn't start a
single one yeah and the most minutes I
ever played was in my debut I played
like 26 minutes and I think the coach
was like yeah we we got this kid and
then even him was probably like where's
your like scrum development going I'm
admit it's just slowly dwindled and
dwindled and dwindled as the years went
on
um until eventually like in my third
season there they just stopped picking
me and then they were there then I was
like oh damn
because I've had some I had some
stinkers in my time and he'd always pick
me because I I was like yeah I'm gonna
get this right I'm gonna get this right
they're gonna get the scrum thing right
and he'd just keep picking me and then
in that third season I was don't think
I'd he just wasn't which I look back
right now it's totally justified I just
wasn't a good Scrambler jet at all I
just it wasn't my focus like even when I
had
bad games like yeah I remember sometimes
in blow up my coach blowing up at me
because I'd have like good games around
the park but I'd give away like three or
four scrum penalties I can't off the
pitch like smiling being like super
happy and [__] and he just obviously my
I just I think my priorities just
weren't there at set P so I just didn't
as long as I if as long as the kind of
we won and I played Railway in the park
I'd just be super happy and
um and yeah and then that third season
obviously just didn't press in my scrums
and he just didn't pick me the whole
year
and then I was like oh damn maybe maybe
I need to sort something out and then
then they had a conversation they're not
going to keep me on and that like proper
knocked me for six because I'd obviously
been like the Super Fan Boy for my
entire career yeah and then all of a
sudden they just told me see you later
and I was like oh damn this is my first
proper but my first proper like hurdle
in my career where I realized that like
[__] I'm not I'm not actually that good
I need to actually I got a lot of work
to do if I really want to be the player
that I thought I was going to be
um
so yeah I I then had a conversation with
my dad about moving over to move over to
the UK because I had the passport so I
wasn't I was I was English qualified so
I didn't count as a foreigner and stuff
so it was quite easy for me to
logistically to get over there
um and yeah that conversation was
initially the idea was to try and get a
gig over here and come for two years and
develop my scrumaging like my dad's
always been very honest with me and he
was just like yeah you need to get
better at x y and z
um and there's probably no better place
to do it than in up in Europe where in
traditionally like the set piece game
over here is a lot more attritional
um especially back then I don't think
the case anymore I think Super Rugby has
come so far in terms of its set piece
and stuff
um but back probably seven eight years
ago it was very there's a big divide
between the two
um and then yeah I spoke to spoke to a
few teams and every every team I spoke
to was just like yeah we love you game
around the park I don't think you're
good enough to scrum up here and I was
off everyone's gonna have to think the
same sort of idea you know like I
remember them making me this one team
maybe like put put together a
compilation of like my training session
scrums not even game ones I wanted to
see training sessions of like on a whole
training session they didn't want me to
pick up the good scrums I got they'll
like send me clips of like your unit
sessions and stuff and I just put
together this compilation and like half
the scrums I was getting [__]
is not going to go over well so I'd like
send them off and they'll be like thanks
but no thanks and I was like oh
[__] uh and then I got it off I got an
offer through from Scarlets in Wales
and like I just remember Googling the
the town and it's like it's innocent
athlete which is I only know how to
pronounce it now because my wife is
Welsh and Double L makes that sound and
I was like where the hell is linelli in
Wales and I was looking at this tiny
little town I was like this is so wrong
it just looked Grim
um and that I was I was literally like a
couple of I was like a day away from
Silent ambian I did get this is my only
option to like go develop would probably
be good for me it's just going to be a
massive lifestyle change
and then London Irish came through with
a gig and I think the dor then was Glenn
Delaney who's a kiwi man so I spoke to
him on the phone and he was like yeah I
think I can develop you like we
obviously love every other party again
but you need to develop it scrum time
and we think this would be a good
environment for you to develop and this
was this is when Irish was I don't know
if you heard the same thing I don't know
when you signed with Irish but they were
still in the Prem it looked like they
were they were sweet yeah yeah and I
remember I signed with them and been
like I was looking at all the Prem teams
be like this is gonna be all this is
gonna be sick and then I remember they
went on this mad losing streak towards
the end of the year
and I was just watching it go down down
and I'm that that had the game they
needed to win against Newcastle was like
the winner of this game gets relegated
and me my brother and a few my mates got
up at like two in the morning and found
this shitty stream of RSV Newcastle and
I remember I'll never forget I didn't
know him at the time you know tanksy
Greg tongs and I remember he threw an
intercept and they scored until I pretty
much lose the game and I had no idea who
who he was or anyone I was you know [__]
you great talks just like Effingham
blinding at the TV because we just like
because now instead of playing the Prem
I'm gone and playing Cornish Pirates
away yeah
but yeah in all honesty that was
probably the best like I need to go and
thank donkey for that because it's
probably the best thing for me because I
was so not really describing the
Premiership when I first rocked up
but when I did Rock up to the UK it was
such a shock to me set piecewise I
remember yeah our first day I came and
we did the yo-yo test and like I
remembered I ran like a 18 something and
you know all the other all the other
front rowers got out at like 15 like 16
was at Max I remember around like 18 4
or something and I beat I beat like I
got pretty much the same as like Jacob
Atkins and all the other like the inside
backs and stuff yeah and everyone was
just looking at me like what the hell's
going on and I was like it's of my
priorities were just like I want to be
lean I want to be fit I want to run
around the pitch and I was just like I
think it was at like
115 kilos or something yeah so even at
this point you are still feeling like
that like even though you'd left the
force you've been sick because you
weren't a scrum your priority was still
to just ball play you're a loser yeah
you're a loser I just believed I could I
could learn this scrum thing but I just
wasn't like I'm Gonna Keep all the other
all the other parts of my game and then
yeah I came into that preseason and I
was still lean and just like I really
like I was actually making expansive
priority but I just like I don't know I
just wasn't I didn't have the right
profile for it essentially yeah I
remember those first couple of unit
sessions I had with George gibbington
and those boys
and I just was like it [__] smoked me
I remember we're doing these like long
45 second like isometric scrum holds and
sometimes they'd like without telling
you they'd add an extra couple of back
rows it'd be like a 10-man scrum against
eight and I'm sitting there this look
this like young sleen tight head just
sitting there who's never done anything
like this and I remember there's a few
of them where I was in there and I'd
come up and I'd just be so light-headed
and I'd be like stanky legging around
the place but all these bugs look at me
like who's this kid and I literally get
out of these grounds I couldn't even
breathe and like the black the black
circles were coming in and I was I'm
gonna pass out and I was like just don't
pass out I closed my eyes and prop
myself up against the fence and try and
stay stay conscious
um so it was just like the biggest shock
to my system yeah
um and then like that's why I said the
champ was probably the best thing for me
because it allowed me to that first year
it would allowed me to like progress
pretty slowly in a way like some of the
games we played like I don't know if you
probably because when I came in they had
Frank C who is starting at Target so I
was like kind of second or or third
choice title coming in so I played some
of like the the champ games with gritty
but I played some of the real good again
being like cup you remember did you ever
you never played the BNI cup I had a few
so I remember playing like Ospreys a
which is like their like reserve team
full of their Academy kids in like in
Neath which is a small little Welsh town
and it was like seven people watching
and it was just horrible I remember
doing playing that game it was one of
the first games actually started for
Irish and I still I was getting I was my
scrums I was getting bummed by this like
Academy little Welsh kid and I was like
I've got like 30 games of Super Rugby
like my last game before I came over
here I think we played the blues at Eden
Park and I was like what is going on but
I come here I've done this whole
preseason like finally I'm gonna get the
scramming energy thing and I was still
getting done by these like
these like little kids who probably are
part-time this is the Welsh kids and I
was like this is just like never
clicking for me so it kind of just let
me sort of fail in silence without being
on the big stage of of the Premiership
so how do you how do you learn the dark
arts of scrumaging how do you get there
eventually getting bummed so much as
actually and actually like making it and
then I like I know I kind of it humbled
me even more by getting done by
part-timers essentially yeah um it's
just like
it uh it it humbled me a bit more and
allowed me to kind of really really
realize that I have to put most of my
energy and focus into this aspect of my
game and realize that the rest of
the rest of my game will be like will
get will come naturally because it's
like it's that's that's the part that
I've focused on for so long on my skills
and that sort of stuff my and my engine
and stuff is just going to be there
until I really focus on
this is being my actually swapped my
priorities about this is what I need to
focus on to to have a long successful
career and Achieve what I want to want
to
then then that's called that shift sort
of came in my mind and I went I remember
Kendo bring him in and being like I want
you to put on 10 kilos and he told me
that initially and I was like oh yeah
I'll do it I never really I just didn't
really do it and then I was like okay
I'm gonna put some weight on and get
like
turn into a normal hemisphere prop
essentially and I I put I went I got up
to like
120 627 kegs
um and really sort of like locking in on
in unit sessions and and every time ever
we're going into a game all I'd like all
my notes and everything and all my focus
and all my analysis would just be around
scrum because I'd be like the rest of
the stuff will come I really started
putting a focus on it and I started to
see some progression towards the back
end of that year
um
and then I had a few a few good
performances towards the back end of the
year where I scrum pretty well
um but still like I'll still come off
the bench remember in that like final
um promotion game at the Mad stat yeah
I'd set Friday I didn't get on the pitch
did Frank see go 80. if I actually went
80 but then yes that's what I mean which
would [__] me even more because I
thought I was I thought I'd get on at
least the last 10 and be on the field
and we like won it and then Frankie went
and punched some bloke and got recorded
and I was like I guess I'm sitting
Friday it was Kevin a decent uh swings
too I don't know Frankie can throw so he
went he punched someone and then I like
sat Friday and I was like that was kind
of like the rest of my my season I come
off the bench and get a few get to have
a few good good sort of better
scrounging performances and then we went
to the Premiership year
um and they brought in Petra's duplicity
it was like a scrumaging specialist so
yeah I started that season not even not
getting picked
um so that was like another thing I was
like God I gotta work even harder now to
try and just get back on the bench and
then maybe try and become a starter
um and yeah that then Petrus was
actually Petra was Master for me he's
pretty much he was like a scrum coach
and player essentially I think that's
also why they brought him in
and he taught me a lot
um and then I can't remember who but
someone I started the first couple of
games not not getting picked and then
someone got injured and I was on the
bench for a few times a few games and I
think there was another I can't remember
I think Frankie might have got injured
for a little bit or something and I
started a few premiership games and
actually went all right
um and then I kind of just the back end
of that season I just saw it was I think
when Frankie came back they moved him to
loosehead to accommodate me starting I
tied it and I was like oh damn this is
actually starting to fall into place a
little bit
um so I had like I was I started I think
the last half of that season and really
sort of
found my groove a bit and was playing
well around the park and scrums are
going well and I was scrubbing against
all these guys who are like seen play
internationally and stuff like astrology
against Joe Mahler and gang and all this
sort of blokes so I'd seen and I was
like holding my own against someone oh
damn I can actually it was kind of like
a massive confidence boost for me being
like I can actually do this yeah
um and the back half of that season went
really well apart from the fact that we
got really good at it again and I was
straight back down in the champ Where I
Belong
um so like the coaching staff kind of
got got fired towards the end of that
year
um just as I had like probably had about
six or seven Games Starting
and sort of become the starting the
starter and then they got fired and I
was like oh these new coaches don't come
in and just like stack me off straight
away but they but but they got they kind
of kept the status quo and I think I I
played I kept playing pretty well
um and sort of kept my gig as a starter
there for the rest of that season that
kind of springboarded me a bit into that
next year down in the championship where
I like feel like I really
sort of found my groove
um and was
playing some really good rugby like I
got to the because it was weird in in
the UK system every League you go down
for the Premiership there's one less
player on the bench that used to be the
the rule so like because Match Day Squad
was like 22 man in the champ and then if
you go down to net one is like 21 and
they like go down because I want people
to play more to like develop I guess I
don't know it's kind of a weird system
so we used to in that second year I was
in the champ they used to put one prop
on the bench and I'd just play 80 every
week so I just
went from my whole professional career
pretty much being off the bench or third
string kind of playing limited minutes
to having like half the back half of the
season in the Premiership starting and
then I had this whole season in the
championship where I just played so many
minutes and was like yeah every single
game I was starting and
and just log in so many scrums and
playing I play really well
um that year
and that kind of just really instilled
this confidence in me being like
actually I'm I can do the set piece
thing now
um
and then yeah and then we went back up
into the Premiership and
yeah and then it just kind of kicked on
from there I still had like so many so
many times where you I felt like I'd
figured it out after that year and then
we got back in the Prem and there was
still so many portions where I was just
like
had runs at games where I was just going
so poorly and I got dropped again it was
just like you know how it is every time
you feel like you've got to figure it
out somebody would come and just smack
you in the face and I'd just be like oh
back not getting picked now getting and
he just gotta like stay the course and
it's actually like roller coaster isn't
it I know that I know it's all
culminated in the last month of the
highest emotional roller coaster ever
was it even an option for you to uh go
somewhere else obviously you said that
um you've done the championship then you
played really well on the Premiership
when you got your opportunities back
down to the championship was it ever an
option for you to jump ship like I did
and not go down to that championship for
another year because uh yeah you'd
already been there
um the probably like I explored it a
little bit but in reality like I kind of
wanted to stick with Irish they they
pretty much offered me the same sort of
deal I was on to like kind of go again
and they they wanted to spend the next
year or so in the chat really developing
me
um so I once again I kind of signed that
contract even though we we've got the
what the writing was on the wall that
first time up in the Prem pretty early
like we we won that first game against
Queensland I think we won again until
like round 16 or something we were just
getting against the cleanser game yeah
yeah
to stay alive mathematically and then we
beat we beat Queen I don't know how we
got the double on them that year we were
pretty average
um
yeah uh I'd already kind of signed and
to me like I didn't really mind once
again I didn't really mind going down to
the champ because I still felt like I
had so much development to do yeah
um because although like I had a few
around a few a few good games in the
Premiership I still knew that I wasn't
like I was no by no means like a
dominant Scrambler during the premier I
could just find I found a way to kind of
hold my own so that I could let the rest
of my game speak for itself so I still
had heaps of development I needed to do
um so going down to the championship
wasn't the worst thing for me once again
I just kind of used it as a sort of
training ground in a way where I was
like I just really focus on scrums and
luckily I played so many minutes that it
like helped me develop massively for the
next time I went to the Premiership
um and then yeah then once we got back
up there it was once again it was like
some some games that went went pretty
well and then others like I probably to
be honest that second time went back
into the Prem I didn't have as good a
season as I had when we were in there
the first time I don't know it was just
like every time I feel like I've figured
out scrimmaging something comes along or
someone comes along that you just like
it just there's always fine it always
finds a way to Humble you you can you
never can rest on your laurels because
as soon as you think you've got to
figure it out someone comes and just
pops out the top and you'll say oh God
here we go again and you go back and add
like a lot of mental demons around it
too because I had this like running
narrative so many so I'd been told by so
many people and so many coaches that I
was a bad scrummager that even when
things were going well I just was I'd
put it down to be like Oh I'm lucky that
it went well I didn't I never like sort
of gave myself credit I'd always be like
every I go into every game being like
just expecting to get get done and if it
didn't go if I didn't I'd be like oh
that was that was lucky like I hope that
happens again so like every time I'd
have like five or six good games on the
chart and everything I'd have one even
just one scrum that didn't go my way my
mindset would go straight back to being
like oh God yeah here we go I'm a bad
scrabberger like we're back and then
that would just like
it's not everyone to me having put maybe
a couple of a couple of bad scrams into
me having a bad game into me getting
dropped oh God then the cycle would
start again and I'd be like okay I've
been dropped now I've got to really put
in time and work and get better and then
I start going well again and then same
thing would happen I'd have a couple of
bad scrums and then I'd just like
catastrophize everything in my mind so
much
it was just like so frustrating because
I put in so much effort and I wanted it
so bad but I just have this like mental
block around my scrimmaging where I just
like I hope this doesn't go bad I hope
this doesn't go bad and every time went
well and be like okay didn't go bad and
then it did one of one or two would go
up the [__] and I'd be like
um crap again and I just had this like
running narrative in my mind which was
which is like a big demon for me to get
over which I only really got over
probably
probably like when I was 27 20 I
probably that like season that I met
ended up making the wallabies
remember going into pre-season there we
had a full-time Sports psych with us
um at that point and I worked with his
name's Mike Roberts and I work with Mike
around
trying to shift my mindset around being
so results focused like I'd I'd be so
focused on the outcome of things
that that would just completely dictate
whether I thought I did a good job or
not or whether I was happy or not so
I've gone to every every scrum and be
like just focus on me I remember it's
just like it may sound silly but this is
what I'd like I'd have this voice in my
head I packed down on a scrum and this
is how I'd motivate myself I'd be like
I'd make fake scenarios in my mind and
be like if I get this scrum right like
if I don't get penalized in this scrum
or we go well I'm going to play I'm
going to play International Rugby that's
just like I tell myself that to put
pressure on myself to make sure I got
this scrum right and then when it didn't
obviously I'd be like oh man I'm done
I'm dust so I just had I've had such a
Negative bad relationship with set with
with the scrum like and it was so weird
because almost if you're scrumaging is a
completely different sport to rugby yeah
because like being a rugby player around
the park was sweet like I'd still I was
still like super fit I'd get through so
much work I'd make all my tackles I
carry I do I'd be sweet and then I'd
just view scrums as a separate entity
that I just like
put so much pressure on myself because
I'd been told for so many years that I
was bad at it I put so much pressure on
myself to get it right and then
I work with Mike around becoming more
sort of process driven rather than
results and focusing on things that I
actually like actually can't control
like I know you've never been a scrum
but the reality of it is like eight
essentially eight people have to get
their get their [__] right in order for
it to function optimally and sometimes
you can do your job 100 right and
something else goes wrong
and you're the one who end up ends up
getting getting [__] and
then you can as big a tight head you're
kind of like the linchpin of the scrum
so then like if scrums go wrong they're
never going to blame blame the the
second rowers or the or the or whatever
um it's always kind of you're like in
the focus point of what's going on
um
I remember the season before this the
last game of the year I was starting
against wasps and it's just after cover
so we just got crowds back in the in the
stands and I'd like had an up and down
season same sort of thing I have a
couple of good games and I'd have a
couple of bad ones get dropped make work
way back in the team and I was starting
this this game against wasps last game
of the season
and like
started the game on fire around the park
I think I got I got a jackal I was like
Karen making good meters we're up by
like three tries in the first 25 minutes
and we had like four scrums and I got
penalized every single one of them all
right every single one I remember this
local Tom West there's actually
something for Sarah's now I'll be
playing with them he just he just um he
just messed me up I know one of those
guys just couldn't figure out and I got
dragged 26 minutes in wow like Deca
kidney just pulled me just pulled me and
I remember I remember feeling like this
big and I walked off the pitch and
obviously the camera's right in my face
and I was just sitting there like trying
literally trying to get an injury
literally I didn't even I didn't even go
I don't know what they're saying the
comments probably like he must be
injured or something but no I just got
like fully fully just dragged and I was
uh sitting there with a camera in my
face trying to hold together and we went
in at half time and deck was like mate I
just had to had to do it I'm sorry but
it is what it is and once again I was so
just like so frustrated like so so
frustrated that I like in half time like
went to the toilets and just like cried
because I was just like I just can't get
this thing right
um so then after that in that off season
I started working with this psych around
my scrum so I had such a poor
relationship I went and spoke to him and
I remember
as I was speaking to him he's like you
want to go for a walk and chat about
stuff and I literally just started
crying to him about scrums because I was
like I just can't I'm trying so hard and
I've been told I'm so [__] at this for
so long and I sometimes I get it and I
feel like I can do it and then I just
like have this horrible relationship
with him
um and he sat me down and we made this
like
process pyramid is what he called and we
like put together like the foundations
of what a successful scrum looked like
for me and all my answers were like oh I
do I get a penalty or I do this or it's
all results driven like the outcome and
he was like that's 50 perspective into
what actually you can control every
single time regardless of what goes on
what can you control going into a scrum
that had the opposition or anyone else
has no influence over and let's make a
pyramid of that
and then judge yourself
on that it how you went about doing that
Instagram rather than if you got a
penalty or you didn't or you got
penalized and that was like a real I'd
never thought about things that way I'd
always been like it's good it's black
and white it's good if I get a good
outcome it's bad if I get a bad outcome
and there's no gray area
so we like really focused in on what my
mindset was going into each scrum
like little little technical things that
I can control 100 of our foot placements
where what I'm focusing on on the bind
all that sort of stuff around my mindset
and then everything up to the engagement
we put together this sort of like
checklist that I could mentally go
through and if I checked all those
things off and I could generally say
that going to the scrum I had an
aggressive mindset and I did this this
and this
regardless of what the outcome of the
scrum was
I can live with it and move on to the
next one and if I've got a good scrum
fine I didn't get too high and if I had
a bad one I was like okay whatever I'll
move on to the next one and that was
like a real Revelation for me because I
never thought of it and it took a little
bit of time to like really implement it
and then once I like really started
viewing not just grounds but rugby and
life in general like that it just
everything sort of fell into place for
me and then after we had that in
pre-season going into that year
us would have been uh yeah lost it so
not the season just gone the season
before that when I I just like was
flying but it was the best best days of
my career by country mile
um I started like majority of games I
was
and even when I didn't like and the same
sort of thing around selection even when
I didn't start and I came off the bench
I'd just be like whatever if I play if I
play 30 minutes I play a half I play 10
minutes I play 80 minutes
whatever portion of time I get on the
field I just commit to the same actions
and go as hard as possible that is what
it is and that just like was absolute
Revelation for me so like even if I came
off the bench I just play 25 minutes I'd
be like I'm going have this 25 minutes
and I'm committing to the same actions
whether I start bench whatever it's
never going to affect my mindset going
in
um and that just manifests itself into
like maybe easily playing the best best
season of my career and then the
wallabies thing came around which is
another complete story in itself where
that came out as a completely keep going
why I don't have to ask any questions
yeah sorry I'm just rambling I'm just
rambling yeah um this the wallaby thing
came around which was just like
completely out of the blue like we
played sarri's the
the Saturday before that and we had this
ridiculous comeback and this is one of
those games like oh I honestly think
it's one of the best games I've ever
played in my life because we were down I
think we're down by like 26 points in
the second half and we had a red card
and I came off the bench and I don't
know before I came on I was like I'm
just going to empty the tank and I think
I'll actually I'd know for a fact how
many calories and stuff I had within
this 26 minutes because I remember
looking at afterwards being like I think
something came over me I had like seven
I had 17 carries in 26 minutes wow that
was just like like just went [__]
nuts I was running I was one of those
guys I was like running over people and
stealing the ball I was like I'm just
getting my hands on the ball every two
seconds how did the scrums go it was all
right mate we're down to 14 we're down
to 14 men and I think I gave away one
free kick and one of them only had two
scrums was probably why it went so well
I only had two and I got one I got one
free kick and the other one the ball
goes in and out
um because we were like down when you're
down to four to seven man we're just
like get it in hooker quick and go so
maybe going backwards the balls already
out but I was just like I'm just going
nuts this game yeah so like
um yeah we had this mad comeback and we
came from 26 points down with like 30
minutes to go and we ended up drawing
with the last kick of the game [__]
unreal and so like I was on a high from
that and the next day like I'm off the
field I'm like a massive nerd so I play
I play Dungeons and Dragons with these
with these guys every every week like
massive nerd we role play and I'm like
rolling Dice and I'm like this we're
just enormous nerds so I was literally
at my mate's Place playing Dungeons and
Dragons Dungeons and Dragons how good is
that how does that actually go I've
always is that that game they play on
that movie like do you dress up and I
don't dress up some people do we don't
dress up but uh you're fully in
character and stuff like I've got a I've
got a character that I play and I've got
a he's got a completely separate
personality and you role play and you're
in this other world and stuff and it's
like the polar opposite to Footy that's
what I'm saying like I like I have these
like two identity I've got like the
rugby player and then off the field
unless it's completely different which
as I said like it's helped me so much in
terms of footy because I can just
completely disconnect from rugby outside
of work and I'm lucky like my wife
doesn't really like rugby or want
anything to do with it like so I don't
come home and she's not asking me or a
thousand questions so I can just kind of
completely disconnect I see Play Dungeon
and Dragons she does I've got her into
it
yes so she she's I run I run a game
where she's involved now so I've never
been more attracted my life my wife in
my life when she rolled those Dice and I
was like let's go be a nerd with me
I might have to give it take it up
Dungeons and Dragons sounds like a hell
of a Sunday event
but unreal so this was the best Dungeon
Dragon session I've ever had so I was
literally mid-session like just being
I'm a little like my character in DND is
this little halfling she's like a little
hobbit essentially so I'm just running
around being this little hobbit doing my
thing
um
and my phone kept buzzing in my pocket
and we have like a no phones policy when
we're playing and it just kept button
and I was like sorry I need to check it
and it was um Petrus duplicate who's
like the wallaby scrum coach and we
obviously played with
um and he
he was like Instagram messaging me being
like Oh mate how I uh do you wanna
um just give me a ring when you have
some time sorry mate playing funny
dungeons sorry mate cool yourself
yeah so I was um
I was watching the wallabies play
earlier that day they played Scotland
and I saw Alan alatoa and taniela both
get injured in that game but I never
like I literally didn't I've never
spoken to the wallabies once in my whole
life and never had any contact with any
coach nothing and I was like I knew the
laws had changed because of covert they
changed the laws they could pick
overseas player
but they'd never contacted me or
anything so I was like oh Paramus just
like they're obviously playing England
next week once you should come and
learning problems catch up for a beer or
whatever and just see what's up
um and so we had a break in our session
I went to the other room and was like
and gave Petrus a call and he was just
like uh how are you mate yeah
um see you're going really well for Iris
this year um we need you in wallabies
camp tomorrow
and I was just like excuse me this is
like it's a proper gr or something
um and yeah he literally was like yeah
both the boys have come down we didn't
bring another we didn't bring a third
tight head on tour
because we always like had you in mind
as if she hit the fan over here we'd
just call you up and I was like it was
nice thanks for letting me know
thanks for letting me know mate I had no
idea so I literally like got that phone
call and was like literally like
having a physical like my body went numb
as I was talking to him I was like keep
it cools like oh my yeah it'll be
awesome that sounds good can't wait uh
he was like yeah I just got to get some
things checked off I'll let you know in
the morning
if if we need you but I was like it's
we're pretty certain that we're gonna
we're gonna need you for this week even
if you don't play like just come in and
train with the boys and and do whatever
I was like that's awesome let's go
um so like I was like so rattled
just uh I had to go in and we we cut the
sessions short our DND session was cut
short which is Blasphemous but I was
like guys I actually can't play right
now like I'm just like so overwhelmed
and I like was walking walking home
called the wife toddles up woke my mum
up and my dad up because they live in
Malaysia yeah my parents live in Kuala
Lumpur so it was like a big big time
difference and I like woke my dad up and
I was like Dad I could be going to
wallabies camp tomorrow and he was like
get [__] because he was like to be
honest like because I've been English
qualified like over here I thought the
only chance of me playing International
is if I got picked for England so I was
like I told Dan he's like you've got big
for England because my dad's English he
was like so excited and I was like no
the wallabies I want me to go camping I
was like ah well that's awesome too
there good thanks Dad
um so the next day I just went to
training with Irish like because I
hadn't he hadn't had anything confirmed
I'd let that obviously contact the coach
said there's a chance I might I might be
um going to Camp so I just went to
training with Irish and I was in the
middle of a gym session and and Kissy
our head coach came in was like yeah
mate they want you at the lensbury which
is just down the road in Teddington
wanted to go to the Lansbury and go to
camp and I was like
Jesus this is actually happening and
same sort of thing like I just like
walked out walked out the middle of the
gym session and was like on the way to
the car the team site came over we're
just we're meant to have a chat a catch
up and I told him
what's going on and once again I know
with him but just like I was such a good
relationship with Mike I felt so
comfortable I was talking to him about
it and just once again I just got so
emotional I was like oh my God this
might actually be happening
um and I chatted to him and then just I
hopped in the car and drove to the team
Hotel I had like I was in full London
Irish stash had no kit nothing uh and
just like rocked up and just like kind
of went to the lensbury and like went to
the room and there was a few of the boys
there and I was like um I don't know who
I meant to speak to or anything and then
like the team manager came it came over
and like gave me a room key and was like
yeah we need you for the week
um and I had to drive home and get
clothes and silence she had nothing on
me
so I had to drive home and then I was
with them for the
for the week and they had like a really
short training week so right at the end
of the season obviously that spring tour
they do at the end of the year they've
played so many games and boys were
battered so I think they played in the
Sunday and it was a six day turnaround
to the
to the England game so they weren't
training like the Monday
I think it was like just a walk through
on the Tuesday then we'd train let me
train uh Wednesday or Thursday I think
um and then like Tuesday morning we had
a
oh sorry Wednesday morning we had a um
a meeting and they just announced the
team and I was on the bench and I was
just like this once again no they didn't
they kind of told me that like I think I
think either Eleanor taniello would be
I'd only play if both of them were out
because if only one of them is out
they're going to move slipper to tight
to cover tight head from loose head and
then that one of them would be on the
bench
um and I'd they'll both of them were
kind of like yeah I think one of us
would be right they both got concussion
so they both went through hiaas and that
sort of stuff and none of them I didn't
get told before this meeting once again
that I was in with a shot and they just
like read this team out like number 18
Ollie Hoskins and I was just like oh my
Lord I went from 48 hours before never
talking to the wallabies before in my
life to getting picked to play against
England and I was just like that this
video went out and I just like was
sitting there and you see I hold it
together for a bit of like clap and I'm
like and then I just like I was just
like Water Works in the deep and these
guys are looking at me and I'm sitting
there like trying to like hold together
I've got tears streaming down my face
she's like this is Inc like the most
wild 48 Hours of My Life
um
and yeah and then I just like went
through the week and like the stars
couldn't have aligned anymore obviously
playing at Twickenham was literally a
home game for me yeah like I live in I
live in Richmond like 10 minutes up the
road so like my um and also my mum
happened to be in the country at the
time as well like she was over visiting
her her folks
um so like everything just lined up and
then I went on and and came off the
bench and I played like 13 minutes off
the bench and it literally felt like it
was done in two it was just like it was
just like in this trance the same sort
of thing we were learning and I ran out
onto the pitch after warm-up and stuff
um with like my whole body was like
tingling we'd lined up through the
national anthem and I like looked
directly across from here as my my mum
my wife and my dad flew in that morning
from Kuala Lumpur and I saw him and they
were all there and I was just like
crying again singing the National Anthem
I was like I'm just gonna be known as
The Cry guy or whatever because I'm just
like this whole week has been like so
many tears
um and they've just gone like viral on
socials and stuff so I had like
thousands of messages from people it was
just like so overwhelming
um yeah and then that 13 minutes went by
like that I think I made made a couple
of tackles and then just like had a
couple of scrums which went all right
and I was like okay this is like and it
was just over and I was like oh damn
that was so amazing the build up was so
incredible and the game went so quick
and I was just like oh damn that's like
I guess that's my wallaby career done
like
and haven't heard from them since no not
since it's not really they kept me off
they they kept kept me on for another
week when we went to Wales um yeah but
both of the other boys passed HRS but I
stayed on just in case and like trained
with them and stuff and was away with
them for that for that week
um in Wales and then yeah kind of
said thanks when I said it was and never
spoken to any of any wallaby people
again pretty much it blows my mind that
is crazy yeah what a what an
international experience it's like the
shortest most intense the like week of
my life and then it's just like thank
you for your service cheers mate here's
about you see you later crazy but it was
always a massive dream of yours too well
I think I saw a message an old message
of you yeah from one of your mates are
saying that you're gonna be a wallaby or
yeah it was like it was kind of it was
doing that message I sent I sent my
brother it during covert
um oh yeah and I was like like we were
in I was in the middle of lockdown I was
just flogging myself just like had this
like Renewed Energy being like I'm gonna
I've always wanted to play International
Rugby I remember to like telling my dab
and I was like five years old being I
want to play after one of these and I
was just like oh it's always been my
goal to play test match
um and moving over here like I thought
the only realistic chance was because
the wallabies because of the laws in
Australia I was like if I'm gonna happen
it's going to be for England and once
again like I've never I was too
inconsistent over here I'd only really
had one that last season of where I got
picked for all these as well I was like
consistently like one of the best tight
ends in the Prem playing really really
well for like a long period of time
um so I never real I never got a sniff
at England and I was just like
frustrated in the middle of covert and I
remember texting my brother being like I
just I'm gonna make this happen I was
like give me
I'm just gonna go so I'm gonna go hard
for the next two years I remember I
think I said I'm gonna go ham for the
next two years to my brother in this
text and I'm gonna play test out rugby
um and at the time I thought that
because I didn't think I was allowed to
get picked for the wallabies I was like
it's going to be like I'm gonna play
test match whether it be for England or
whoever
um and then literally nine months later
or like it was a bit more it was like a
year and a half later I think then this
this happened and I was just like
weird weird manifestation probably
probably a coincidence or whatever but
I'm gonna put it down so I manifested
that [__] like I believed it and brought
it into reality
um and yeah it was just like a little
flash in the pan sort of thing
but yeah as I said I got the I got the
cap I got the number like I'm probably
949 even if it was for 13 minutes but
I'm always gonna always be a wallaby
which is pretty incredible when you
think about it now all right so cool so
you're a chance to play Rugby World Cup
are you selectable like how does that
work nice in the country yeah so you
have to though they've changed the laws
where you can they can pick three
overseas players but you have to have 30
caps so they're gonna they'll imagine
they'll pick something not 30 seconds
not 13 minutes unfortunately if it was
13 minutes 30 minutes I still wouldn't
have qualified but 13 that would be fun
um so I think they're probably gonna
they're probably gonna pick Samu and
Quade and then probably corabetta or
someone like that
um I'd imagine I think they've got a
little bit more pedigree than me
unfortunately
oh well one day though because you're
still you're still so young for a prop
really aren't you you've spoken about
like pictures
about 39 we've just said John Affair
join us at the age of 39 so he's still
talking plenty of years later I know and
I played with Augustine Kirby this year
and Gus is like 38 and still running
around there's a spring chicken doing
all this thing yeah he's gonna go I
think he's going to go to his fourth
world cup
far out that's an achievement ridiculous
yeah and he's he's so there is hope for
me that I've still got it quite a few
years left and my body's feeling pretty
good touchwood that everything stays fit
like I still want to kick around for a
while so I'm not as I said like I've got
this next two years at sarri's and then
we'll see what happens after that like
I'm not rolling out the fact that I've
played my last test match
um so we'll see what happens but I had
exciting times ahead in what about life
after footy is it um Dungeons and
Dragons or oh imagine imagine what
what's the dream is that professional by
the way can you play that can you get
paid to play that there are people who
make a lot of money on it if you go on
YouTube the people who like stream it
and stuff and get millions of views and
make absolute squillions is that the
post footy dream oh mate if I could play
D D for a living would it be
unbelievable well the guys the guys I
play with over here they have a company
that they've written a book for dinner
and they're they're gonna go full time
into that sort of space so maybe the
dream is to like go with them and just
be a full-time nerd after footy yeah
um to be honest what I want to do after
rugby I don't I don't fully know I've
got a I've got a degree in psychology
and counseling oh true now I'm older I
don't no I definitely don't want to be a
counselor to be honest you get more
cynical as you get older but not
honestly just like I don't know the
older I've got the more I like to kind
of prioritize my energy into like things
that really matter and people that
really matter to me so I just feel like
I'd be so drained for like if I had to
take on and like everyone else's sort of
problems not like I'd have a newfound
respect for even doing the court doing
my degree and stuff like being a
full-time mental health person is like
you're it takes a toll on you just as
much as the other people because you're
just vicariously taking on everyone
else's stuff
um so I actually don't know if I've got
that in me but
I think it's taught me a lot of stuff
about how to relate to people and it's
got a lot of transferable skills so you
know that like being a professional
Sportsman like it's the ultimate team
environment so like any sort of Industry
I feel like where
you have a group of people working
towards any sort of goal
Pro Sports Plus psychology and that sort
of stuff sort of sets you up perfectly
for that because as you know you have to
be this is taught me you have to be
[__] adaptable to be a pro footy
player you gotta you gotta take feed you
take feed you're getting judged every
every action you do at work every day is
being you know the other one doing the
judging now but like you're getting or
you're auditioning every single day for
your job for your selection all that
sort of stuff so like I'm great at
taking feedback all that sort of stuff
so I'd imagine whatever I end up going
into
I figured out all of my wife's yoga will
pop off and I'll be his dad home Dad and
I'm pretty yeah you know we don't we
don't want those traditional gender
roles man I'm happy with being a
stay-at-home dad and letting her bring
home the bacon after after footy mate
with that degree you're pretty sorted
I'd imagine you'll have plenty of
opportunities we'll figure it out yeah
count me away and plenty of time on your
footy career to go before then as well
but as always we've gone to our
Instagram for some questions and plenty
came in for you um plenty of good ones
too so we'll try and get through a few
of these
um first one best Sledge you've been on
the end of
no this is actually this is the story I
told recently actually I'll tell again
against your lot the Crusaders oh you're
kidding yeah my uh my first year of
Super Rugby I was like just turned 21.
um we're playing the Crusaders in
Christchurch and I came off the bench
um and there was about 20 minutes to go
and we had a yellow card in the second
row so I had I had a I had a flanker
behind me in the row and he had molded
Soul boots on
and our front row was was Francois van
Vick who plays for Leicester now
he's he's tessman who's like a bit of a
older veteran and me and I was like 21.
and the front row the crusaders had out
was I was against white Crockett then
they had Corey Flynn at Hooker and Owen
Franks at tight head oh so like and we
had I had a boulder I had a flanker
behind me in like little nipple studs
and and we were like we've had these
it's like the worst nightmare for a
tight end like any prop it's so bad and
we had they had scrums five meters out
from from our Driveline and the first
the first one they pretty much almost
got a pen try but they managed like I
think they knocked it on and then they
reset had another one I went down
straight away in the second one because
I was under so much pressure
and then it got penalty again and then
the third one
white Crocker got under me and he lifted
me off the ground and as I was up in the
air he goes take your medicine boy and I
was like oh please sir please and he
just like lifted me up and I pushed us
over a penalty try and I was just like
another one of those games where I felt
like this big and I came off the pitch
just being like Oh my God I think I want
to retire I felt so embarrassed and he
just like looked at me and said take
your medicine boy and I looked at their
front row and I was like all of them had
like 100 All Blacks caps and I'm just a
little kid who just played like five
Super Rugby games getting absolutely
wrecked uh that was yeah I'll never
forget him telling me that's the best
legend I've ever had oh mate no wonder
you're mentally scared
it started with white Crockett
absolutely melting me in Christchurch
oh right that is a yarn that is a good
one so did you did you ever wish you'd
never made the transition into the front
row like obviously you're a Lucy I feel
like you're a Lucy at heart hearing your
stories like you're good around the
field you've got all the skills tackles
carries and then for some reason you're
put into this front row which you hate
and you've got mental issues around them
for the first until probably three or
three or four years ago I cursed it
every day I cursed it because it was
just like the scrums were literally just
the bane of my existence because
everything else would go so good and
scrums would go bad and I just
catastrophize it and I would just be so
annoyed all the time
um but now I look back on it like
knowing the
where I am now and The Business of rugby
title is a specialist position and I'll
tell you if this had happened now
probably like what's happened with Irish
last couple of weeks and I was playing
number eight
it'd be way harder for me to find a job
than it is right now as a tight head
like if you're a if you're a good tight
end you can play a long time as you've
seen and yeah it's like it's an
in-demand skill and it's a it's a reason
it's in demand because it's [__] hard
man it's so hard and it's just it's just
one of those skills that you'll never
quite master and yeah so I'm glad I have
now but there's so many times I've
cursed it like I remember the man who
this it was my old Academy coach called
Matt Tink and Tinky was like one day
he's like because I was
it was like a hundred and I was like 120
kilos when I was like 16. I was just
massive that's right so he was just like
and back in the end I was playing number
eight I could literally just like run
over everybody and before school boys I
think I was 17 when I played like West
Australian school boys it was like we're
gonna move you to tight end
and just give it a shot and back then I
could do it because I was like 120 kegs
playing against 80 75 80 kilo kids and
just like monstering them but yeah that
was uh Tinky thank you now but I've
cursed his name many a time
oh that is good stuff okay next one best
pre-match talk he remembers oh pretty
much talk
um our captain this year Matt Rogerson
he was he's honestly one of the best
leaders and talkers that I've ever been
a part of he's just one of those guys
that like
he plays in such like a in a way that
just like Garner's respect he does all
the [__] like he doesn't get any
accolades for anything he's a six who
just like
just runs head first into the thing will
hit like 500 rocks and make 35 tackles
and have no highlights but he's just
like such an awesome player and he as a
leader
we're just like he's a northerner so we
get up and he'd talk in front of the
front of the team and be like
disciplined and [__] get up in their
faces your bastards yeah it's just that
and it was just I don't know every time
Rod spoke he just like everyone was just
locked in and he could just like it's
almost like listen to Jon Snow and Game
of Thrones and just like Inspire the
troops to go so I can't remember a
specific
pre-matched speech that he did but this
is so many this year where he just chats
you know you've had a few a lot of the
times when there's a pretty much talks
and stuff you just kind of like okay
whatever but every time Roger spoke
you'd just be like get this inspiration
um so yeah he's Matt Rogerson is a is a
hell of a leader yeah what a legend love
there okay next one lucious unit at
London Irish on the pass
hey Lucy goosey went back in our time
back in our time there's a few Gilly
Gilly was good wasn't he
kind of Gilson
absolute lad and he was so good were you
either had you left by the time you
organized that pre-season
um trip and he like we're meant to just
have like a court session and stuff and
he bought everyone tickets to this
festival and just hopped us on a bus and
no one knew where we're going and we all
dressed up and we just got off at this
like massive Music Festival we had no
idea yeah I think I was after after you
left like Gilly was yeah Gilly was some
of the best times on the drank um yeah
I did a few trips with him like like we
went to Prague once which was just like
absolute
absolute send it
um yeah and he just thought he was head
of the social committee when he was here
so
um Gilly was great crack and then Jack
cooked remember cookie he was a young
boy yeah cookies still around until this
until this year he was still like he was
like our social he took over from Gilly
after after Gilly left um and yeah
cookie was great value on the on the
drink always always dressed up as always
cross-dressed every single every single
theme he'd find a way to somehow wear a
dress or something dress up as a chick
it was just fantastic
right was it on a social that you met
your wife is that yeah you were there
you were there the night I met my wife
was I remember at the end of our first
preseason we went to Swansea yeah on
that big piss-up and she was that the
nightclub we went to she managed that
nightclub
and we went to that dinner before where
we were just blind when we got kicked
out of the restaurant because boy
there's those big wooden beams and boys
like doing chin-ups on the roof and
swinging and besides we were so pissed
and I literally like look I can't fully
remember the first interaction I had
with my now wife because I was just like
sideways and the bar we went to that it
was called peppermint and it was like a
Wednesday night I think we were there
and they were doing that rock paper
scissors thing with the bartenders I
don't know if you remember and you go
there and any order you do any drinks
order you do if you pay rock paper
scissors and if you win you get double
oh true boys like lloydy will Lloyd and
stuff are going give me like 20 20 vodka
Rebels and be like win and we get a
thing of 40. the boys are just like just
absolutely so I was sideways when we
first met and like uh yeah this is
actually one of the my marriage hinged
on this one this one act here because
her her mate came over and was like oh
what do you think about her and I
literally couldn't even see I was like
oh yeah
um and then she was like walking she was
walking around she was stone cold sober
but she was working she was walking
around doing stuff around the nightclub
uh Sora walked past me and this is drunk
and all over this could have ended my
marriage before it started
I stuck my foot out and intentionally
tripped her up but then I caught her
this is like this if I if I'm not caught
it she would look to me like this guy is
an absolute wanker never talk to me
again but I caught her and grabbed her
and started dancing with her midday and
I was blind and somehow that worked and
then yeah and then look at us seven
years on was we're married we've been
married for two years wow wait mate
that's like another movie you could make
a dancing scene literally I wish there
was some hidden camera or something I
could see that night again because I was
all of us were so pissed and she was
Stone Cold Sober and somehow it worked
out and then she started then then we
just like within we did that that was in
August and then by January she moved to
London we're living together wow one of
the great love stories yeah I know it's
so romantic isn't it it's so good okay
mix one uh best honey badger memory phew
honey badger beds in the world isn't it
Como what a man
um oh bad yeah he was I'm he's just so
many one-liners from that bloke and the
thing is like the stuff he did on camera
wasn't like a person like a media
Persona or whatever he's genuinely like
that off the field too just like such a
free spirit and so Rogue I remember one
but probably my favorite memory with
Como is we had this one plane trip I
think we were going to I think we're
going over New Zealand to play someone I
can't remember and he was he gave me
this book about like
uh
uh like people having previous lives and
it was about how past life therapy and
people who are like going to these
meditative States you can remember past
lives they've lived and he gave me this
book and was going off and it's like
he's quite like a spiritual guy going
off this like round about we all live
how we all have lived past lives and our
souls every time we've upgraded and all
this sort of stuff and it was actually a
fascinating book I read it was actually
really good
um so yeah he was that's that's one of
my core memories with badge and then
also like he's just one of those players
who just like run fit like literally
face first into everything like was not
the most skillful player or anything but
he was just like built on just being a
little wired differently and going so
hard all the time right sounds like an
absolute lad the honey badger lots of
fans out there okay next one what's one
thing you'd like to see changed in a
rugby
one thing Alexi changed I think there's
nothing wrong with the product of rugby
at all I think it's such an entertaining
game whether it's a Premiership Super
Rugby anything the game's like when you
actually sit down and watch the games
the skill and the product is amazing I'd
love to see the mentality around players
being able to Market themselves and
promote themselves change a bit um I
feel like
you know it is that the way why I think
NRL back home and in New Zealand is so
popular why NBA why American Sports all
this sort of stuff why like the Premier
League over here all the football stuff
is so popular is that those guys are
allowed to kind of have this unique
personality and really have this unique
Flair and promote themselves whether
it's through B3 like celebrations or
stuff on Tick Tock or whatever just the
way the world is now
um and that also carries over into the
crowd like I I this is the UK thing like
I love how I was watching the super the
other week and when the kicker was
kicking people the Chiefs fans were like
ringing their bells and trying to
distract him but all that sort of stuff
I reckon that's awesome whereas here
you'd know
the thing comes on it's like okay you're
not allowed to speak when the guy is
doing a thing you watch the NBA guys are
shooting free throws and people are
waving stuff like just doing everything
is distracting me like engages the crowd
into the game like I don't mind a bit of
sledging all that sort of stuff and it's
so frowned upon in rugby
and also if you like to celebrate too
too much after scoring or you've got
some like too much Flair that sort of
stuff it's it's very much still like an
archaic sort of team first no don't put
yourself above the team ever or like
show Too Much otherwise you kind of get
vilified a bit especially over here I
think it's I think it's developing in
New Zealand a lot better slowly yes
slowly slowly yeah but I feel like that
whole mindset has to change because
that's going to bring a younger audience
into the game and show them the like as
I said the product is so good that if
they could just allow players to
Market themselves and therefore
vicariously Market the game to this
younger audience then I think they'll
sort so much out and allowing people to
allow the crowd to get involved and
sledge and have a bit more of like a
it's a bit more like a tribal feel
around things you know it's so it's so
uh black and white and straight up and
down sort of thing that I feel like it
hasn't evolved with other sports have
and really captured like a a grasp on
the marketplace where Rugby's kind of
filling off a little bit which is a bit
of Shame yeah I like that and you're in
the right position to to change it mate
let's see some try celebrations
good scores on first mate who to score
some oh God you're enough okay two more
questions what is your dream lid if you
could choose any haircut what would it
be
not the one I got right now but I'll
tell you that much I'm bored as anything
and I'm gonna this is better I haven't
shraved in like two weeks I've got a lot
of peach fuzz going on right now like
look how fuzzy this is
hence why the Hat's on
um it had a dream lid God I used to I
held onto my hair way too long I used to
cop so much [__] when I was at the force
because like I started losing my hair
when I was like 20 21 and you see it's
so funny I watch myself like any footage
of me playing Super Rugby back in the
day you know that top end camera angle
is not very forgiving when you're sweaty
as well and you've got thin hair and
every time every scramble every time I
do something you get up and you see me
doing this combing it over just combing
my hair over all the time it was so
self-conscious of it
um oh man I wouldn't mind just knowing
the feeling of having some long locks
once you know just like having like a
man bun or something I just feel like
for a bald man the thought of having
like a man bun is just so foreign that
I'd love to just you know if I could
just pop up tomorrow and just have like
long flying locks even for a bit I think
must be so nice
at least you got the choice you know you
can you can choose if you want to go
bald you can but you have the choice of
various I'm stuck with either completely
shaving or the old man sort of ring
around the sides and that's about it
well you'd look good with some long
locks I can see it blonde are you we
blonde
yeah I was like a mousy Brown sort of
Blondie back in the day like honestly no
one over here has known me with hair so
they look at old pictures of me with
like the comb over and stuff and they're
just like oh my God I'll do is this
Blood I'm lucky my wife likes thick bald
man otherwise I'd be in trouble yeah
mate you do be smarter
okay last question best piece of advice
you have for a woodland listener
um I think I'll hop back to what I said
before
um try to experience a multitude of
things don't pigeon yourself your
self-identity into one basket even if
you've got someone that you're super
passionate about and you love and you
want to put majority of your energy into
it 100 that's one of the main reasons
I've been successful in rugby is because
especially in the younger years I was
obsessed like especially before I made
professional when I was in like the
academies and stuff I was like
unhealthily obsessed with rugby I'd
literally go to school
train a company I didn't I literally
didn't have a cheat meal or like
anything I considered to be bad food for
like five years straight because I
didn't have a like I refused to have a
alcoholic drink before I was 18. I like
didn't I remember on Christmas like my
family and stuff I knew that like I did
I refused to eat chocolate or anything
and they'd literally buy me protein bars
because I'll be like yeah I don't want
anything I was so manic about being a
pro rugby player which obviously paid
off but at the same time I'd neglected
so much fun experiences in my youth like
after after we finished
um
oh year 12 exams I'm sure you have the
same sort of thing in in New Zealand we
did this thing called levers where all
the people have recently graduated we go
to an island off the coast of of wa
called rottnest and everyone's just
parties for a week or whatever I didn't
go because I I like I didn't I had like
two Academy training sessions although I
can't miss these training sessions and
like all there's like all these core
experiences when I was younger that I
just didn't do because I thought in my
mind I'm like if I if I didn't do these
things I wasn't going to make it or I'd
be like I'd make it they'd be like oh I
bet the guys I'm competing with are off
partying at leavers now I'm gonna go and
do this one Academy session it's going
to make all the difference in my career
when obviously that mindset has helped
me be really disciplined
but I was that I put all my eggs in one
basket and that also led to me
catastrophizing [__] when it went wrong
like my scrums and stuff because I was
just so rugby focused all the time and
really when I had the last two or three
years when I've let a little bit of the
grip on the Rope go and I've just
relaxed a little bit and approached it
with a bit more of a mindset around
going into it to have like enjoying
myself playing not putting so much
pressure on myself
and having a great support group and
stuff outside of rugby like being a nerd
and playing DND and like having all
these other aspects to my life
once I've done that my Rugby is actually
improved tenfold because I don't
catastrophize things and put so much
pressure on myself
which in turn has actually helped me
um so whether it's rugby or anything in
life find what you're passionate about
but also make sure you have lots of
aspects to your self-identity because
when one thing goes wrong like it has in
the last month you'll have other other
legs of the chair to kind of prop
yourself up on and realize that if
you've got a good family and you've got
good friends and you've got good
relationships and you've got things you
enjoy hobbies and stuff that if [__]
goes tits up professionally then you've
got other things to kind of fall back on
I hate what a piece of advice and what a
what an insight into your mindset
especially as a young kid like that's
that's really fascinating hearing I was
amazing Universe to the to the to the
cause and um unhealthily obsessed I'd
say looking back on it now but I mean it
worked if it didn't work out I don't
know what it would have done but it did
luckily yeah hey yes so interesting it's
been a awesome podcast really appreciate
you coming on
um and giving us uh insight into not
only your mindset what's happened with
London Irish but your career as well
it's been yeah really interesting to
hear it from your your side of the view
and I'm looking forward to obviously
following your journey for the next sort
of 10 years as you continue your journey
as a front rower
um especially at saracens and then
wherever you end up but
um and probably finishing with a bit of
D and D to professional data finish
right what important I'm literally gonna
go YouTube a little bit of that now and
see see what it's all about there's a
rabbit hole mate don't get too involved
you might have to you'll be neglecting
your family with the amount of time
you've got to put into it
it's a part-time gig
but do appreciate you coming on the
podcast mate giving up your time you're
an absolute lad thanks brother